I'm Jessie this is Zuri I'm her nanny
I'm Teddy Disney Channels Jessie was
much more than a TV show but was so much
going on behind the scenes it was easy
for viewers to miss out on the mini
easter eggs
cameos and inside jokes flashing across
the screen do you know which cast member
made it into the Disney Channel Hall of
Fame because we do stick around to find
out there are tons of inside jokes goofs
and easy to miss references in the
season 3 finale episode Jesse's Aloha
holidays with Parker and Joey this
one-hour special crosses over with
Disney Channel's original series Liv and
Maddie's Joey Bragg and Tenzing Norgay
trainer who played Joey and Parker
Rooney are the only cast members to
appear in the episode however Joey does
drop Maddie's name once or twice
throughout the crossover special my
sister Maddie Jessie and the kids run
into Joey and Parker while vacationing
in Hawaii but things get a little hectic
when a nearby volcano erupts Jesse's
aloha holidays with Parker and Joey
serves us the series fourth and least
popular crossover and some eagle-eyed
viewers quickly pointed out a plot hole
at the end of the episode
this happens when Ravi tells Parker that
the volcano is erupting and Parker looks
at Ravi like he's speaking gibberish in
reality Parker should have known what
Ravi was talking about since he is
pegged as a science whiz in the Liv and
Maddie series to take me on and a game
of refrigerator roulette the 4 w Ryan
was cast as the lead in Jessie she
starred on the spinoff series the suite
life on deck for a total of 3 seasons
during this time she worked alongside
Disney alum Phil Lewis who played the
one and only mr. Moseby on the set of
the suite life on deck Debbie was known
as bailey pickett so when mr. Moseby was
involved in a crossover episode of
jessie things got a little confusing for
him in the episode titled Karate Kid
cast Rafi Emma gets suspended from
school and runs a
to the Tipton hotel where she crosses
paths with mr. Mosby when Jessie finally
locates her she heads to the hotel where
mr. Mosby ends up giving her some advice
shortly after mr. Mosby called Cody
Martin to tell him that this was Disney
Channel's way of acknowledging that
Jessie and Bailey were not the same
person
despite being portrayed by the same
actor this reference flew over the heads
of viewers who had never seen an episode
of the suite life on deck this isn't
goodbye I know I'll see you in two weeks
at the math Olympics it's easy to forget
that many Disney Channel shows occur in
the same universe but we're reminded of
this a handful of times and Jessie we
already know that the sweet life and
live in Maddy franchises take place in
the same universe as Jessie and since
both the Hannah Montana and Wizards of
Waverly Place have had crossover
episodes with the sweet life it's safe
to assume that all five of these shows
occur during the same time line but if
we take some of the other shows
crossovers into account we find out that
Jessie also takes place in the same
universe as good luck charlie Austin and
Ally
shake it up Girl Meets World I didn't do
it and best friends whenever Jessie and
Austin world tour because that's not
what I'm saying
Jessie just wouldn't have been the same
without its leading lady Skye Jackson
the young actor portrayed this sweet yet
mischievous Zuri Ross and would go on to
reprise her role in the spin-off series
bunked but did you know that Disney
Channel had a very different vision for
this character before Skye audition for
the role the Zuri we know and love was
born in Uganda Africa before being
adopted by the Rosses but originally
Disney Channel had planned for Zuri to
be an American girl named Olivia from
Chicago producers were so impressed with
Skye's audition that they chose to
rewrite her character completely they
decided on the name Surrey
instead of Olivia which means beautiful
in Swahili following the changes
producers also chose to model Zuri's
personality after the main character in
The Roxy Hunter movie franchise Roxy was
known for
sassy witty and sarcastic and Disney
executives wanted sky to take a page
from her book unsurprisingly sky Jackson
exceeded every single one of their
expectations
can you imagine what Jessie would have
been like without sky playing Zuri Ross
yeah neither can we or Jessie tries to
make me do chores Disney Channel hasn't
always been keen on allowing their
actors to direct the shows that they
star on but executives chose to make an
exception for Debbie Ryan in 2014 Debbie
became the youngest female to ever
direct a Disney Channel production which
landed her a spot in the Hall of Fame in
total Debbie directed four episodes of
Jessie from 2014 to 2015 she directed
the episodes titled identity thieves
dance dance resolution Bye Bye Birdie
and coffee talk you're gonna have to
learn to appreciate this kind of humor
but Debbie didn't have this honor handed
to her she worked hard to gain the
respect of the writers and producers
before bridging the gap between actor
and director yes I see
maybe it would be faster to send me a
list of things you don't need a lot
happens in the episode titled punch
dumped love which guest stars the
legendary Adam Sandler are you just
trying to pick up some spare change
chaperoning Disney Channel wanted to
give Adam a big friendly welcome so they
came up with the title punch dumped love
to pay homage to Adams movie punch-drunk
love but this isn't the only reference
the episode has to offer as it turns out
Adam Sandler chose to appear on Jesse
because he was close to one of the
show's stars and whenever possible do
this
this star was Cameron Boyce who had
previously worked with Adam when he
portrayed his son Keith E better in the
grown-ups movie franchise Adam and
Cameron managed to squeeze in a
grown-up's to reference during the
episode
this happens when Luke meets Adam
Sandler at the school dance and says if
we have to have grown-ups to who I'm
glad it's you did you catch this
reference tell us in the comments
Disney's Jessi is known for welcoming
dozens of famous actors to its set but
few episodes where a star-studded as
basket-case
in this episode cast members had the
chance to meet and act alongside the
famous NBA player Chris Paul is also
about hard work and commitment just as
much as Talent however this wasn't the
first time an NBA player had
guest-starred on the show
Chris Bosh did make a cameo and say yes
to the messy dress after all basketball
fans were thrilled to see Chris Paul on
the show but some viewers were too busy
focusing on actor Nagi eater who guessed
Stardust Harry to notice the NBA player
just like Cameron Boyce and Adam Sandler
Nagi also had a role in the grown-ups
movie franchise so Cameron welcomed his
former co-star to the set of the show
but did anyone notice a certain blonde
extra in the background scenes of
basket-case this extra would go on to
become the YouTube sensation papi the
cast of Jessie had no way of knowing
that they were sharing the set with the
future popstar it is in every day that
the first lady of the United States
clears her busy schedule to appear on a
Disney Channel sitcom in fact throughout
history first ladies have seldom
appeared on television shows at all
Disney Channel's Jessie had the great
honour of welcoming Michelle Obama to it
said and it was a groundbreaking moment
for Disney and Zuri sneaked into the
Oval Office to ask the president to
institute bedtime reform however it was
Michelle Obama's second time appearing
on a teen sitcom she made her first-ever
appearance on the Nickelodeon show
iCarly in which she guest-starred on the
episode titled
meet the first lady so although Disney
Channel wasn't the first network to cast
the first lady of America they
definitely evened out the score out of
all the first lady's Michelle Obama is
the fourth to ever appear on a TV
program you see both the President and I
know how much you and all our military
children do for our country keep
watching to find out how Debbie Ryan
earned herself a spot in the Disney
Channel Hall of Fame are you trying to
make me because it's kind of working in
the episode tidal lights camera
distraction Jesse attempts to direct
shoot and edit a small movie for a Film
Festival but instead of doing this all
on her own she asks the kids for help
and things get a little complicated to
most viewers the scenes that the kids
chose to film didn't come off as strange
or familiar
however some viewers quickly realize
that many of these scenes were parodies
of well-known movies in a scene directed
by Emma Jesse and Tony pretend to be
star-crossed lovers of the werewolf and
vampire variety this was meant to be a
parody of the Twilight movie franchise
next up Luke comes up with an
action-packed scene and pitches himself
as the leading man in Luke's daydream we
see him driving a convertible with Jesse
in the passenger seat how about a
high-speed kiss
[Music]
anyone who watched the double-oh-seven
movies immediately recognized this
segment as a James Bond parody well mr.
Ross while we're on the subject of
parodies we might as well mention the
episode titled the tell-tale duck which
was a parody of Edgar Allen Poe's short
story the tell-tale heart this episode
has a very clever and easily missed
reference in it however it also has a
huge goof that was pointed out by some
very observant viewers in this hilarious
episode Bertram convinces Jessie to pose
as his girlfriend at his high school
reunion but Jessie and Bertram take
things a little too far and soon their
lives unravel for all to see the same
happens with Ravi and Luke who steal a
game and lie about it at one point Luke
says you're supposed to run from the
mummies that walk like an Egyptian
towards them but only those who have
listened to the band the bangles will
recognize this reference after all they
do have a song called walk like an
Egyptian next up is the goof which was
brought to us by paint enlist aka
Emma Ross in this episode Emma writes
something down on her right hand to
remember it but it's a well-known fact
that Emma is right-handed so writing
down a clear message on a right hand
would not have been possible and that's
a wrap on the things you missed from
Disney's Jessie before you go tell us
who your favorite Disney Channel star is
in the comment section below thanks for
watching if you love the Disney Channel
give this video a thumbs up and hit that
subscribe button down there for more
we'll see you next time